[Musique]
bakou
[Musique]
en afrique noire le cinéma ne tient plus
à grand chose regardez un film ça tient
à presque rien
[Musique]
alors dans les salles ravagé où des
spectateurs passent comme des fantômes
les actrices délaissé pleure sur des
étrangers
[Musique]
ici l'industrie cinématographique est
insaisissable
bravant l'improbable les réalisateurs
font des miracles avec des films sans
aucun argent les dvd piratés pullulent
tributaire d'un contexte politique et
social fragile la salle de cinéma est
une espèce en voie d'extinction
[Musique]
et pourtant le cinéma a besoin d'afrique
et l'afrique n'a jamais eu autant besoin
de cinéma un peuple sans salle de cinéma
c'est comme une personne sans miroir une
raison suffisante pour réaliser un
voyage inédit à travers les toiles de
l'afrique
le voyage commence au sénégal à quelques
kilomètres de dakar là où il n'y a pas
de salle de cinéma
[Musique]
vous
voulez vous à venir dans le
[Musique]
passé neuf ans passés au maroc
depuis dix ans amadou ndo de
l'association image et vie sillonnent
les villages muni d'un micro et d'un
écran gonflable avec pour seule mission
donner aux jeunes le goût du cinéma
oui on a fait l'essentiel on a sillonné
quelques duels et puis voilà pour leur
annoncer la tenue de la projection de
films inédits du coeur en tout cas voilà
c'est ça parce que bon quand on
travaille il faut de la passion il faut
aimer ce que l'on fait et c'est le cas
chez moi
[Musique]
la majorité des gens se disent ils ne
sont jamais entrés dans une salle de
cinéma donc ils nous voient le film qu'à
travers la télévision
quand j'étais encore petit c'était
vraiment le loisir le mieux partagé à
dakar et partout au sénégal parce que
dans toutes les grandes villes il y
avait une salle au moins une salle au
regard des autres une fois deux fois
même cinq fois parce que les gens à
aimer le cinéma alors moment donné vers
les années 80 et il ya des orientations
politiques qui consistait à tout petit
et maintenant c'est tombé entre les
mains des
businessmen donc aussi des personnes qui
ne savaient bien du cinéma et qui ont
transformé ces salles à un franck
commerciaux ou bien autre chose quoi
donc voila quoi donc que ceux qui
appuient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
waouh ça va mal comme rallye salam
aleikoum maquiller salam aleikoum à nos
filles semaine au festival
- festival de cinéma image et vie ouais
édition spéciale
attention est un film qui passe et de
plumes l'avoir amené relève le jeune
loup mode ahmad ahmad ahmad ahmad
el guendi
regin est au plat est terminée bobby
dixon
[Musique]
je crois que tu n'aies avenir mon lit
j'ai depuis deux jours
en général quand tu tant pis pour lui
cette façon de faire quelque chose qui
ne va pas je ne vais pas te cacher je
suis à nouveau célibataire
explique en détail avait tu n'es pas en
ligne enfin
disons que
j'ai pris avec une autre femme et j'ai
décidé qu'on en reste rait aussi peu
le joues tu trouveras un seul mec dans
ce pays ne tombe pas sa compagne
présente le mois recule heymans ont le
secret
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le lendemain dakar la grande capitale
sénégalaise d'un côté la mer de l'autre
des rues grouillantes et colorée rempli
de taxi jaune poussin
une ville où il ya encore quelques
années vous pouvez facilement se faire
une toile aujourd'hui sur les 85 qui
existait au sénégal il n'en reste que 18
et seulement 4 à dakar et sa banlieue où
les spectateurs s'abreuve de films
hindous et de blockbusters américains
le cinéma est à l'agonie
[Musique]
les salles mythiques de la ville sont en
ruines
ce sont des squats des décharges
publiques
comme le monde source située dans le
quartier du grand dakar à l'intérieur
s'entassent toutes sortes de déchets et
on vient pisser sur les tonnes de
pellicules qui pourrissent à même le sol
difficile d'imaginer que cet endroit
était un sublime cinéma où tous les
soirs plus de 800 personnes venaient
s'asseoir pour voir un film avec jean
gabin
il paraît que la mairie a le projet de
réhabiliter cette salle en attendant
devant l'entrée ont raccommoder on cire
des chaussures
[Musique]
pas très loin d'ici se trouve l'imposant
bâtiment du liberté la plus grande salle
de la ville avec ses 1500 places
ici autrefois ont refusé du monde
que deviendra cet endroit un centre
commercial une discothèque une église
nul ne le sait encore
[Musique]
parmi les salles qui fonctionne encore
en dehors d'un multiplexe hors de prix
pour les locaux il y a le medina le
cinéma bleu turquoise et rouge de khalil
ndiaye
très engagé dans la lutte et exploitants
de salles depuis 15 ans khalil ou
promeut la culture et l'éducation à
travers le cinéma
présenté six films j'ai cité l'euro cote
cécile filmera ont bien répondu à
l'aller c'est de continuer de faire la
même chose et voilà on essaie de faire
des efforts comme ça
[Musique]
le droit aux loisirs c'est un droit
fondamental c'est l'aimant droits des
enfants c'est pas mal que nous envoie le
puisse parler dans les salles de cinéma
quoi tous les enfants tous les pays
c'est une exigence nationale le pire
dans l'éducation la santé l'habitat on a
tous mais là aussi la culture il n'y a
pas que ça n'a pas que l'alimentaire il
faut aussi nourrir de l'esprit le cinéma
et contribuer d'une certaine manière par
la discussion par la critique pour le
développement du sens critique dès le
bas âge en dehors de l'aspect premier
qui est là après l'opération est finie
l'autre aspect politique est derrière
pour nous c'est de développer une
opinion publique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et en fin de journée dans le quartier de
la gueule tapée
khalil où on retrouve son ami amadou ndo
de l'association image et vie pour une
projection dans la rue
[Musique]
ce soir au programme une série de
documentaire africain est un film muet
avec harold lloyd
et c'est par centaines que les enfants
accourent et regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plus tard dans la nuit des images
étonnantes nourri son imaginaire
[Musique]
il règne dans les rues sombres et jaune
de dakar une étrange atmosphère ici des
histoires se joue s'anime comme des
contes des légendes
de tragédie
alors on réalise à quel point ce pays
est puissamment cinématographique
[Musique]
st
non par les mon come on
[Musique]
non
à dakar d'autres initiatives voient le
jour pour donner un second souffle au
cinéma dans le quartier très populaire
de la patte d'oie on charge des
triporteurs pour la tournée du jour une
nouvelle forme de projections
itinérantes
c'est inédit ces voyants et ça marche ou
presque
[Musique]
bon
chaque semaine ses frères lumière
motorisés kadri la capitale sénégalaise
et assure 200 à 300 projections dans les
quartiers la séance est à 45 centimes
d'euro le cinéma accessibles pour tous
[Musique]
et toute cette opération financée en
partie par l'union européenne est
rondement menée par enrico chiesa et sa
société id images les grandes écoles
sept anciens exploitants de multiplexes
parisien passionné de septième art est
venu s'installer ici pour relancer l'
envie de cinéma
des sièges
c'est très solide
la super verra
comment ça vous est venue cette idée ou
auby signer plusieurs choses le fait que
les gens regardent beaucoup de films et
regarde surtout les films indiens ou
américains
les réalisateurs crèvent de faim
mais vraiment littéralement puisque il
ils n'arrivent pas à vendre leur film au
télé enfin toute la consommation de
l'image est illégal
mais les gens eux mêmes ne pirate pas ce
qu'ils n'ont pas internet donc les gens
payent des gens gagnent de l'argent au
milieu il n'y a pas de
et pas de qualité de projection il n'y a
pas d'argent qui revient aux ayants
droit on est comme en europe sous
plafond
assez d'accord et puis au passage il
faut quelqu'un parce que les projections
donc créer des emplois durables c'est un
sacré boulot quoi conduire monter
démonter projeté légers elles vont
monter
et
des projections comme ça c'est simple
mais on n'utilise pas de dvd ils ont le
fichier crypté sur l'or
ordinateur et pour pouvoir le lancer il
devait être connecté à internet a
demandé l'autorisation d'utiliser le
film concert le producteur lui lit en
direct l'utilisation on peut pas faire
de projections qui échappe à la vue du
producteur
[Musique]
tu pleures parce que tu la personne pour
te conter de belles histoires n'est ce
pas
nous allons commencer par l'histoire
d'un enfant terrible
c'était à une époque
où la lune ou street
[Musique]
pass les comptes de l'arc en ciel c'est
des histoires africaines
raconter aux enfants ça c'est pour les
petits et pour les grands mame diarra et
compagnie qui est un film sur une gamine
des rues qui se bat pour aller à l'école
on essaie de mixer des histoires
africaines et documentaires
une pétition
le film était
[Musique]
même des films parce que les films saw
intelligent dit le téléfilm surpris
parce que l'effet boule de mâcon des
histoires des histoires qui sont en face
des choses les plus touchantes et grains
réalisateur face à un public qui
autrement il aurait pas réussi à le
trouver parce que la filière du film est
cassé
en afrique parce que l'argent il est où
alors j'écoute les questions wen au
mazel est-ce que mame diarra a réussi la
bonne question mangara effectivement a
réussi et maintenant elle est en classe
de 5e qui a plus tellement
de structures de diffusion de nos films
et donc ça fait partie des moyens qu'il
faut inventer parce que moins il faut il
faut les inventer rationnement jeu parce
que c'est un moyen du
moteur mais le père mais aussi à
d'autres réalisateurs torah de
demander le team de partager leur
sensibilité moi c'est le plus plu deux
enfants jumeaux qui me plaît le plus
parce que vous êtes faisait beau vous
êtes sincère vous êtes intelligent et
surtout d'autre chose étudier
aidez vos parents ça c'est la clé de la
réussite en ce moment 1 allez-y et bon
courage c'est moi qui vous a plu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est simple on revient exactement au
tout tout tout débuts du cinéma c'est un
métier complètement forains ou le gars
fait tout et où c'est un petit commerce
et donc ils gagnent en fonction du
nombre de gens qui vont venir voilà on
va les cousins et les arrières petits
fils et douanier des frères lumière
[Musique]
après dakar cette nouvelle moto signer
rejoindront bamako au mali un véritable
espoir pour la diffusion et la
projection des films en afrique
[Musique]
dans le même quartier que moby signer à
la patte d'oie se trouve un grand cinéma
de 800 places portant un nom de femme le
christ a
c'est en l'honneur de son épouse que le
célèbre réalisateur sénégalais tidiane
au avait créé cette salle voilà plus de
dix ans genre projecteurs
décédé en 2009 c'est son fils malik qui
a repris la sphère familiale alors malik
règle son pas sur les pas de son père
ça c'est le projecteur ce projecteur
d'accord
donc pas de 35 mm bon là on n'utilise
pas de 3000 ha parce que je n'ai pas de
film de 35 mètres pour l'instant
d'accord pourquoi parce qu'il n'y a pas
je n'ai pas dessus celui qui me fournit
les films me donne des pour l'instant
des vidéo cassettes ou cd moi
aujourd'hui si je prends une bobines de
35 mm je ferme parce que le ce que je
gagne 2 ne financera pas ne serait-ce
que la location du film
[Musique]
non
2 du chant
[Musique]
le bureau de signal
ca c
[Musique]
qu'un scénario écrit par mon père reste
en nous des enfants de les réaliser
[Musique]
tous les films qui sont ici ont déjà
commencé à se décomposer ce qui pose
aussi le problème de conservation
là tu vois une décomposition en fait je
suis toute la la rouille qu'elle a
conservé des films il ya d'énormes le
une certaine fraîcheur il faut que l'air
soit purifiée il faut porter des gants
et autres et tout ça on n'a pas les
moins c'est pas possible donc c'est pour
ça que la plupart des films font
entendre en tout cas en france en tout
cas dans les films de mon père soit en
france sont conservés là bas
je ne venons pas ouvrir suivre
[Musique]
je
bonsoir monsieur
[Musique]
je
d
[Musique]
l'office
donc cinq minutes avant la séance et
j'ai dix personnes
serait plus agréable de 6 ça n'arrêtait
pas ça montrerait que ça fonctionne bien
on peut faire plein de choses
investir améliorer le confort à voir des
foules beaucoup plus récent de meilleure
qualité
[Musique]
c'est durement mais la force je la
prends à travers mon père voilà celui
qui nous donne la force
le pays a besoin aussi qu' il y ait
certaines personnes
le peu de moyens qu'ils on arrive à
maintenir parce qu'ils sont convaincus
que ce n'est qu'un passage et que [ __ ]
les choses iront mieux
ne soyez pas aussi monnaie
docteur moreau
[Musique]
je quitte le sénégal pour l'est du
continent là où un très grand
réalisateur américain a failli perdre la
raison
[Musique]
huit heures de vol plus tard se trouve
l'ouganda un autre monde
pour winston churchill la perle de
l'afrique pour john huston l'endroit où
il a réalisé african queen
avec un très beau garrett et catherine
aime peur de ça il ne reste presque rien
[Musique]
ce pays comme tant d'autres a été
mutilée par un dictateur fou
autoproclamé roi des causses
[Musique]
une tragédie porté à l'écran par
d'autres comme tant d'histoire africaine
[Musique]
alors
oublié l'histoire et la misère
environnante
les ougandais se pressent dans les
grandes salles de cinéma de kampala
ici la salle est le dernier refuge
l'endroit où l'on se rassemble en masse
pour vénérer un unique acteur aux
cheveux longs
[Musique]
à
jésus la mer vous qui
allez vite
macky sall à la casse
les salles de cinéma n'existe plus en
tant que telles elles ont toutes été
transformée en église
[Musique]
et comme dans toute bonne séance il y a
toujours le type qui dort
[Musique]
après la messe le marché
au majestic plaza dans le centre ville
on vend par milliers et pour quelques
shillings des dvd piratés
on y trouve toutes les dernières
nouveautés à peine sorti sur les autres
continuent et les vendeurs font office
de distributeurs en alimentant les 3000
salles vidéo qui foisonnent à tous les
coins de rue et dans tous les villages
[Musique]
et c'est dans une salle vidéo de i robot
est à quelques km de kampala qu'une
séance spéciale matin
[Musique]
les vidéos halle c'est la solution que
les ougandais ont trouvé pour pallier le
manque de salles de cinéma soit des
baraques sombre et étouffante
construites de bric et de broc équipés
d'une télé de banc et d'un vidéo jockey
qui traduit en langue locale les
dialogues des films étrangers
[Applaudissements]
et
lui avec sa chemise à carreaux c'est
jean gotha boulin le plus célèbre des
vies jesse du pays cela fait plus de
vingt ans que jean go apporte hollywood
dans les villages du gang
[Musique]
je traduis les films et j'utilise
différentes langues le soin lit le
l'ouganda
c'est pour ça que je travaille même en
dehors du pays
quand j'ai commencé je voyais ça comme
un amusement jusqu'à ce que je réalise
que je pouvais en faire mon métier
maintenant non seulement ça m'amuse mais
ça me permet surtout de nourrir toute ma
famille et des millions de gens
dépendent de moi dans mon pays
c'est devenu un gros business parce que
maintenant pour tous les gens du pays
c'est indispensable cela permet vraiment
aux gens de s'instruire dans les
familles que les politiciens
grâce à mes traductions les politiciens
comprennent les films c'est pourquoi je
suis devenu très populaire et je passe
même à la télévision nationale
[Applaudissements]
rendre les films divertissants on doit
s'éclater et moi j'adore regarder des
films c'est pour ça que je pense être le
meilleur
j'écoute
ce soir on va voir un night and day
c'est un bon film et l'acteur est génial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque
[Musique]
radio
la
[Musique]
situation
non
[Musique]
nous étions tellement à témoigner
avec le nigeria l'afrique avait son
hollywood soit la troisième industrie du
cinéma au monde avec ses milliers de
films tournés en vidéo à la va vite pour
trois fois rien il se pourrait que
quelques ougandais de waka liga et
décidé d'en faire autant voire mieux
ramon films productions présente
[Musique]
c'est un peu
oui mesdames
après 2 ou 4
captain ali
[Musique]
à
elle est cool je fais le montage je
filme j je réalise
je veux que l'ouganda soit meilleur
qu'hollywood 23 je veux amener sa
wacalie woods
[Musique]
j'ai eu la chance de voir rambo les
films de chuck norris ce que tu sortes
ta gueule et c'est cela que je puisse
toute mon inspiration
[Musique]
c'est que j'ai tourné 26 films en quatre
ans tu peux faire le calcul
et tu tournes tous les jours
presque tous les jours
aujourd'hui on commence à tourner le
film black black le criminel le plus
recherché
tu tombe toujours dans ton quartier
oui bien sûr parce que c'est plus facile
de se déplacer avec ses armes jouets
bien sûr nous avons l'autorisation de la
police mais tu sais notre armée n'est
pas très bien éduqué et on pourrait
avoir de gros problèmes avec eux
certains ne nous connaissent pas et peut
se méprendre sur nos attentions street
c'est pour ça que nous tournons ici et
en plus je peux faire appel aux gens du
quartier
on va la conduire historique
et oui dit tout j'apprécie beaucoup
monsieur usac
grâce j'ai tout appris sur le milieu du
cinéma c'est mon maître et ya
même si on travaille dans les pires
conditions à chaque fois on s'améliore
on va montrer au monde entier que nous
les ougandais
[Musique]
l'aston vendre nos films en dvd nous
faisons du porte à porte
et pour s'en occuper j'utilise les
acteurs c'est mon équipe de marketing et
c'est aussi comme ça que je les
rémunèrent rester avec elle
certains me disent oh j'ai vu ton film
il est vraiment très bon calais est ce
que je pourrais avoir un rôle dans le
prochain et je réponds mais oui bien sûr
il ya de plus en plus de gens qui
viennent me voir et ceux qui pensaient
que je plaisantais ils se sont trompés
je suis toujours resté fidèle à ce que
je croyais je ne gagne pas beaucoup
d'argent mais ce n'est pas ça qui compte
ce que je veux c'est que mon rêve se
réalise et si quelqu'un me dit que mon
film est beau ça me suffit
[Musique]
et ce soir c'est dans le vidéo hall du
quartier qu'a lieu l'avant-première de
rescue teams dernier film des
productions ramon
on déroule le tapis rouge pour le
réalisateur
[Applaudissements]
à maoulida mobile est chocolatier
d'espagne 1-0 gagnent chez l'unique
essai de la béquille ou crevant son
pneu
avant de sa limousine à
laquelle nous avons tous un rôle à
garazi makhlouf zedeck chocolat si on
est leur alimentation est légal
batignolles qui va pousser la
moustache
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et tandis que certains voient des films
entassés dans des baraques de fortune
d'autres à l'autre bout du continent se
font des toiles à la belle étoile
me voici au mali à bamako
la capitale aux murs peints
la ville les canapés pouce au bord de la
route
et où les femmes portent des tas de
choses sur la tête
[Musique]
et ici c'est encore une autre façon de
voir des films dans les salles pas de
siège luxueux ni pop corn mais quatre
murs à ciel ouvert car il fait toujours
beau un rectangle en béton pas en blanc
en guise d'écran et des chaises en métal
[Musique]
dans les années 90 ce pays comptait 60
salles de cinéma aujourd'hui il ne reste
que 5 tout à bamako équipé de matériel
en très mauvais état
et si avant les gens se ruaient dans les
salles du pays de nos jours ils sont en
attente de rythme et d'émotions fortes
très loin de l'esthétique des films
africains
ap
dans un quartier populaire le cinéma el
hilal en plein jour sert de salle de
sport
[Musique]
et la nuit tiécoura projette depuis 15
ans le même film américain en 35 mm
mais pas seulement
[Musique]
mais le cinéma ah oui oui oui
jedessine c'est mon métier c'est mon
premier métier c'est moi l'amour
vient miner ce moment
bon les apparences et les appareils
cayenne c'est marco russ 1 l'afrique
nous on voulait 16 apparaît la passion
approximations les tristesses et moins
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup bien sûr là dedans on
paie pas on peut pas trouver d'accord
ces moyens qui modifiait les
pièces adaptables
[Musique]
or les territoires de libye
j'ai un problème de son bon ça donne pas
commune comme il faut je peux regret ça
là mais il ya plus de temps donc quand
je cherche des appareils là à cause de
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
on sait que oui
on est d'oublier
maintenant comment ils sont trop vie
secret mais bon là obliger m
l'épousé terme elle devrait prêter
l'argent ne fait pas ça c'est ça que les
gens vont passer ses lois c'est ça le
cinéma ça c'est du cinéma
[Musique]
à voir les avions les cinémas passé lui
ce sont les nouveautés on appris de
nouveaux fans donc peut-être vielles il
y en avait près de six ans
moins bien
quoi
nygaard quoi ouah
[Musique]
découverte
pippa s'appelle film alors vous mettez
quoi un deuxième tient somme c'est un
film porno sur les petits enfants là à
partie le 22e et sont plus là sa cause
et ça on commence à 23 0 23e chez nous
ici le procès pour le grand très
influent mais interdits aux moins de 18
ans ça fait venir les gens ça oui
s'ils ont des familles ne peut pas
regarder un film porno sur lui ça c'est
impossible avec les enfants c'est
impossible dans lequel ils sont obligés
venu ici pour regarder des films pornos
vous
bon on dit mieux le son
à cause des bazennes
[Musique]
assommé par le machin
le
des massifs
elle nous
le lendemain à plus de 40 km de bamako
le cinéma numérique ambulant du mali
rôle sur la route poussiéreuse de
campagnols
depuis neuf ans et avec onze voitures
comme celle-ci parcourant plusieurs pays
d'afrique le sénat a réalisé plus de
7000 projection
cela fait sept ans que la belle kadidia
apporte le cinéma gratuitement dans les
villages là où certains n'ont jamais vu
de film
alors ce soir c'est un grand événement
[Musique]
attendu
chez nous c'est comment gryzlov site
alité quand tu viens voir quelqu'un qui
leur amène la colère je pense qu'on va
tous manger se croquer sur coup la
lançant
pour le bonheur de nous tous
les contacts gmail invitent leurs
comptes à madame qu'il a tout de lui à
la période médiane qui pensent qu'un
aperçu qu il m
[Musique]
ils sont islam comme vous voyez venir et
la lie à jamais attaqué le monde social
sinon - d'autres activités sur place
la nuit tombe tout le monde arabe de sa
cape votre but refusé ou pas là pendant
je suis vraiment mal et la can et ils
sont obligés de nous accueillir pas si
ça prend beaucoup de choses mais à
l'approché de ce n'est avec nous
elles fm de sensibilisation sur
plusieurs thèmes et après il ya de
l'orage et tout le monde se retrouver
dans
[Musique]
il
dan dah
[Musique]
je suis jamais dépendante lalanne canada
a meta pourrait le fémur et tassements
bouchut n'allons nous pas qui vous
musicaux mal à briller en épaisseur
keaton rhdp gbagbo aurait du mal à
contenir grille mais banal même famille
à l'ubo jamie damon est bien là à mettre
à nouveau en vigueur amina aux vingt six
data tu as du goût des huitièmes à terme
ce temps là tiens tu aimes santana
diamants canadiens
[Musique]
mais
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rien ne remplace cette expérience unique
de se rassembler pour voir un film
ensemble c'est sur ces images que mon
voyage à travers les toiles de l'afrique
se termine de l'infime partie du
continent que je viens d'explorer
recevra un point commun la curiosité la
même curiosité qui pousse les africains
même sans moyens à s'improviser des
salles de cinéma pas si éphémère que ça
mais
où
[Musique]
e
on
mais
[Musique]